[Música]
buenas noches a todos
y agradecido
nací en argentina hace dos años me dio
este maravilloso país así que es gracias
prometo
ser breve
me importa más corto dura seis horas
así que tengo 18 minutos hoy para
inspirarnos voy a poner lo mejor de mí
para inspirarlos en 18 minutos
y quedarme tranquilo de que si no la
vuelvo a ver nunca más
ojalá que no vuelva más que muchas
importantes pasos felices
[Música]
quien agradeció hoy cuando se levantó a
la mañana y abrió los ojos esta
comunidad lleva de la mano
normal
quien agradeció cuando abrió la regadera
tener agua potable
y agradeció que había agua potable
caliente
menos
quien agradecía el desayuno
que la recepción la comida
tienes relación y aquí en un carro
quiere agradecer su ropa
somos un grupo muy pequeño de
privilegiados que tenemos eso en el
planeta hoy no tenga nunca
pero estamos acostumbrados
a fijarnos en esa gracia
por eso nos cuesta estar felices
voy a ser muy también mucha gratitud
pues soy muy importante
el camino de los oficiales para cazar
nos enseñan a pedir
donde se agradece
y a 16 torsión todos
además de todo lo que tienes uno muy
importante
es mucho tiempo deberías consciente
bueno soy
invisibles al ojo humano guiado por una
energía divina
y en poder dar meses por mirar algo ya
parece que todo
y eso
y si pasó esto del pasado a mirarlos y
eso pasó
gracias una energía divina puedes amar a
dios universo
energía
o crees que fuiste tú
o crees que es ordinaria pero cuando
estoy en otro estado
o crees que te hace quédate en tu
corazón todos los días frutos
o crees que va a ser un trabajo genial a
la construcción todos los días
no lamento decepcionar algunos
es la energía superior que le puede
poner quieras
igual
para calificar
entonces siente nada
habilidad de habilidad
como el error de dos años de mi
experiencia vean muchas personas
entonces
se construyó y una verdadera forma vital
para construir la felicidad es ser
agradecido
ahora vamos a hacer una pequeña
meditación ejercicio porque sentir la
vibración es mucho más
[Música]
voy a usar las piernas los brazos
cómo
y cierro los ojos
y empiezo a respirar por la nariz
[Música]
y no
y me conecto con lo que para mí es amor
[Música]
adiós
unidas
[Música]
llevo 12 horas con 2
y ahora dejo algo olvidado
que tenemos todos los días
ahora
para mis seres queridos
[Música]
para eso
agradezco todo hasta ahora
[Música]
bien
y tú
y ahora
[Música]
agradezco en lo que te voy a comprar
pero es a futuro
[Música]
mejorando mi poder
grado
[Música]
otra vez
y ahora los ojos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
para sumar dos minutos atrás
cientos minutos puede oprimir a este
sentimiento de gratitud y cada día voy
aumentando más cada día está más
las personas
personas
alguna vez conocido en alguien
desagradecido yo no
bien agradecido y feliz
sí
porque las personas
cuándo
díaz y me sentía bendecido
gracias
después del examen
tune gratis tenía 21 años
nuestras primeras bases fueron durísimas
pronuncia no lo diría
mira
después de separadamente mm adentros
espirituales y empieza a visualizar que
me sonaba que corría había que mediante
correr
en cuatro meses
y luego se desplazarán por haber perdido
tanta masa muscular
y practique que sanar los brazos fueron
siete años de búsqueda y práctica
[Música]
cuando nunca
y el dormitorio pronósticos y hoy enseñó
a las personas a que puedan despertar su
potencial ese potencial que todos
tenemos dentro esa fuerza para poder
hacer milagros para manifestar
la mayoría de personas
y eso porque no puedes liberar el
gratitud no puedes estar en dos
frecuencias a la presa no puedes estar
haber sido dejado es como estar en dos
programas de radio al mismo tiempo no
puedes estar en una conferencia
dos genios que dieron a este plano de
diseños favoritos alberto nicolás de
escena
nos dejaron un legado enorme sobre
admiración en frecuencias
cuando una periodista del protón quién
es el hombre más inteligente del mundo
cómo se siente ser el hombre más
inteligente del mundo
ante el peligro los empleos de la tecla
y tesla nos dijo si quieres entender el
universo tiene que hablar en frecuencias
vibraciones energía
toda su energía nuestro cuerpo es
energía el aire y teóricamente en semana
ahora a nosotros esa energía
moléculas átomos electrones que no
puedes tocar ni puedes ver pero esa
energía
y si tú libras en una energía alta amor
gratitud compasión el día de campoo one
una onda electromagnética de alta
frecuencia enseñar que va a encajar con
la misma cualidad iban a venir
realidades que te harán sentir mal y tú
si te gastas un victimó al vacío
pidiendo
esta ciudad nos enseñan a pedir nada a
pedir a ser 20 años
hacer tomadores dar cariño sabe más que
yo por favor de lleno
y ahí el tema de carencia
la antigua forma de agradecer de
antemano lo que pasa que muchos hombres
son mensajes
nos enseñan a pedir y cuando tus vidas
el universo siente que te falta algo y
te devuelve
esta semilla
y situar a veces el día es una señal de
plenitud entonces te vienen más
situaciones
yo enseño que no somos eso
y sea cual sea la causa puede estar solo
porque las religiones muchas cocinas son
buenas
siempre visualizó como todos pero para
romper la eternidad como adiós como un
entrenador de fútbol con como
y siento sobre mirar dónde corre con
dios
aquivaldo hablar
otra vez
si lo después se volvieron a olvidar
cómo conectar
como se hacían
una vez
se acuerdan
salió de nuevo
500 años después jesús puede decir por
favor
los avances
pero
pero así fue los hombres
del original
pero los sistemas de hamas
por favor puede seguir recordarles
porque cuando de nuevo
entonces es la llave que abre las
cerraduras la contraseña de muy fácil
para nosotros estar hasta afuera es
agradecer
y tu mente se alinea tu corazón y si
empiezas a visualizar
que eres feliz anticipadamente agradecer
tu plegaria como si ya fuera cucharada
la antigua forma de orar izquierdo hace
agradecer de antemano lo que quieres
lograr tu mente se lo cree y tu mente es
lo que le da una señal a el corazón que
todo está bien te apagaste aquí mi gran
estrés y genera el lugar de felicidad
entonces tu cuerpo empieza a cambiar tus
genes cambiando la expresión genética
modificados
sanas
y si te visualizas abundante con todo
ahora momentáneamente está pasando una
carencia tu polvo sólo envía una señal
electromagnética de gratitud de
abundancia de plenitud y eso va a traer
como un imán
la situación es que te hará sentir más
profundamente y cuando vengas a tu vida
qué vas a decirlo
y te conviertes en una persona que
ejercitó la gratitud y a veces hasta la
mano
y entonces hay crearte esa necesidad
y sólo con tu conexión divina siente que
no te hace falta nada y con los
siguientes no te hace falta nada tienes
todo
no se cuentan ansioso y no se puede
estar triste
en cualquier situación y ver el ejemplo
puedo decírtelo hacia los sueños cuando
llegue a méxico mi hermano los grandes y
toda la vida
y yo no lo hago porque para mí existe
porque somos energía en la energía no
muere se transforma
si puede servir agua en una paga y te
olvidas evaporado
nava por el agua no dice es mejor que yo
el color
cambio estado
entonces de su muerte es un joven con
paradigmas instantes conocer las
propiedades
entonces
ya no estuve sufriendo
agradecido de todo lo que me mire y
llevarlo adentro
entrañable a extrañarlo
dice que solamente cambio de estado
y como no hay amor condicional
pase lo que pase
estamos listas digamos
entonces en cualquier condición tienes
que conectarte igual como lo sabes
el general de adentro hacia fuera los
carbones
de adentro se fuera
turnadas porque éste había esperado
viviendo estas irradiando que los bienes
que faltan
historias te levantas y abre los ojos
empieza a celebrar de lo pequeño a lo
grande
y cuando vendida ha resultado que es más
y más verde y más general y más ejemplo
es para otros
y los recuerdos como sebastián
nadie si hacer cambio y de ver en el
mundo
se cambió
[Música]
[Aplausos]
entonces a la socia de su vida
se arrastran recuperen la obra de arte
de nuevo
pero todo
y harán de ella algo para que otros
puedan verla inspirarse y poder hacer
otras cosas
así que yo le doy las gracias
estoy viendo su futuro
las quiere hacer porque
han logrado abundancia gracias por el
senado
y
y nosotros
agradezcan
bien estudiado
gracias
[Aplausos]